madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de cette édition la planète est la
fièvre le réchauffement climatique est
bel et bien provoqué par l'homme le
constat est alarmant en 2100 la
température moyenne aura tout le monde
aura augmenté de 1,1 degré à 6,4 degrés
déjà les dérèglements se font sentir
ségolène royal propose une série de
mesures pour la jeunesse à grenoble hier
soir la candidate socialiste annoncé
vouloir créer un droit au premier emploi
une carte santé jeunes et a permis de
conduire gratuit aux nouveaux titulaires
de ces ap devant la justice neuf
personnes atteintes d'un cancer durable
poursuivre l'entreprise dans laquelle il
travaille l usine
adisseo qui utilisait une molécule
suspecté de provoquer des tumeurs
la chine premier pays au monde pour le
nombre de peines de mort prononcées
exécuter la chine sur la sellette de mal
les militants abolitionnistes réunis à
paris
lançons un appel solennel à une trêve la
chanteuse américaine de gospel la plus
réputée en france liz mccomb est ce soir
en concert à paris la chanteuse
américaine vient de sortir son huitième
album des chansons inédites et d'autres
du répertoire tous les clignotants sont
au rouge la planète est la fièvre le
réchauffement climatique est déjà en
marche notre responsabilité est en cause
un bilan en forme de réquisitoire pour
les experts mondiaux réunis à paris la
hausse des températures celle du niveau
des océans la fréquence des canicules et
des cyclones leur ampleur eh bien tous
ces dérèglements ont déjà commencé avec
avant la fin du siècle à degrés à 6
degrés supplémentaires et c'est
considérable frédéric mentait daniel vit
notre chère planète bleue est en train
de virer au rouge
en haut les hausses de températures
prévues dans les années 2020
en bas celle prévue pour la fin du
siècle à ce rythme là l'augmentation de
la température du globe oscillera entre
plus 1,1 degré et plus 6,4 degrés en
moyenne 3 degrés en 100 ans
il ya une seule chose dont on soit sûr
c'est que les températures vont
augmenter
quoi qu'ils fassent même si par magie
ont stoppé toutes les émissions rappel
voici les vagues de chaleur française
estivale observé sur 30 ans en 2050
elles occuperont tout le pays et
dureront plus d'un mois conséquence les
glaciers fondent déjà dans les alpes
certains ont rétréci de 1 à 2 kilomètres
en un siècle le niveau des océans va
s'élever de 18 à 59 cm 40 cm en moyenne
en charente-maritime 50 cm de plus et la
mer remontera jusqu'à rochefort certains
pays risque de connaître l'exode
climatique les impacts des changements
climatiques dans un pays comme le
bangladesh à peut-être l'implication qui
dix vingt trente mille de personnes
doivent quitter les terroirs dans lequel
ils ont là
ferme la maison en fait des millions
d'hommes victimes et responsables usine
habitations et transport aggravent les
effets de serre c'est désormais une
certitude fiable à 90%
dernière preuve en date en australie la
grande barrière de corail se meurt elle
blanchit attaqué par des pluies acides
et des eaux toujours plus chaudes
l'urgence est donc là notre planète est
menacée par le réchauffement climatique
à ce constat sans appel des
scientifiques la communauté
internationale devra maintenant apporter
ses réponses c'est aux politiques d'agir
jacques chirac devant les représentants
d'une cinquantaine de pays réunis à
paris pour une lancement d'une
organisation des nations unies pour
l'environnement appelle à une révolution
écologique une triple révolution on
écoute le président d'accueil face à
l'urgence le temps n'est plus aux demi
mesures
le temps est à la révolution au sens
authentique du terme
la révolution des consciences la
révolution de l'économie
la révolution de l'action politique
il faut construire un gouvernement
une gouvernance mondiale de
l'environnement
l'unilatéralisme
dans ce domaine aussi mène à une impasse
de même qu'il est la condition de la
paix
le multilatéralisme constitue la clé
pour un développement durable
illustration des ravages déjà observée
par les experts dans les mers du
pacifique de légères modifications de
température de l'eau ont de grands
effets avec à peine un degré de plus
c'est toute la biologie marine qui est
bouleversée alain de chalvron aromates
la région de montrer est connue pour
être une sorte de paradis maritime avec
ses dauphins ces baleines c'est orques
que l'on vient voir du monde entier un
paradis dont froide en raison d'un
courant glaciales de l'océan pacifique
un paradis en danger non plus être
montées d'eau froide comme avant et donc
sans eau froide nous n'avons plus de
créer là sept petits crustacés
indispensable pour nourrir les baleines
bleues ce qui se passe c'est que ces
baleines reste maintenant très au large
parce que montrer est un paradis
maritime l'université de standford une
des plus prestigieuses des états unis il
ya installé son laboratoire de biologie
marine
au delà des microscopes il ya ce récif
terrain d'expérimentation idéal ou
kunisch un millier d'espèces différentes
dans les années 30 un professeur a mené
une étude exhaustive sur ce rocher il
recensant toutes les espèces trouvées et
une reprise ces dernières années même
rocher même recensement est ainsi qu'on
le redoutait
on a pu mesurer l'ampleur du changement
les espèces vivant dans les eaux chaudes
venues du sud sont de plus en plus
abondante mais d'autres espèces
disparaissent ou vont en direction du
nord où les eaux restent plus froides
exemple cette année mme demers c'est une
espèce qui n'existaient pas ici il ya 60
ans et aujourd'hui elle est dominante
c'est typiquement une de ces espèces du
sud qui ont trouvé ici les conditions
pour leur développement
cette étoile ocre en revanche espèces
nordistes très abondante dans les années
30 a presque disparu
c'était une espèce importante du reste
un prédateur le fait qu'elle disparaisse
en abondance que tu avoir des effets en
cascade sur l'équilibré écologique du
récif
ainsi entre 60 et 70 % des espèces du
récif ont changé et le plus inquiétant
c'est que la température moyenne de
l'ona augmenté en soixante ans que de
huit dixièmes de degré apparemment donc
très peu de petits changements peuvent
avoir de gros effets et c'est pourquoi
il est temps de s'occuper sérieusement
de l'accumulation des gaz à effet de
serre tout système écologique étant
extrêmement fragile
celui ci ne fait pas exception la
disparition des éléments les plus petits
peut donc provoquer celle des plus gros
s'agit-il de dérèglement climatique en
tout cas le centre de la floride a été
victime d'une violente tempête
ressemblant à une tornade qui a surpris
les habitants dans leur sommeil près de
l'ecc city 14 morts des centaines de
toits arrachés des maisons détruites
avec des vents de plus de 120
kilomètres/heure défense de
l'environnement encore avec en france le
recyclage des voitures hors d'usagé plus
d'un million et demi de véhicules sont
collectés par an il ne s'agit pas de
s'en débarrasser tout simplement mais de
les traiter en neutralisant les éléments
potentiellement nocifs mallory et uno
olivier robert elle est venue ici pour
mourir
en fait cette voiture va connaître une
nouvelle vie depuis mai dernier les
professionnels agréés doivent valoriser
85 % du poids d'un véhicule hors d'usagé
d'abord ultime toilettes la dépollution
pneumatiques batterie puis sont extraits
les fluides toxiques huile liquide de
freins ou de refroidissement
on repart et s'il veut faire sans le
pack avec soi gasoil et prend une
interview certains liquides pourront
être brûlé pour produire de l'énergie
le casseur intervient surtout dans la
récupération des pièces détachées
seulement quand elles sont vendables une
voiture qui rentre chez nous qui a une
moyenne de poids compris entre 800 et
une tonne 2 à au moment où elle part au
broyeur sort en moyenne dans les 600 700
kg le groupe du recyclage se fait donc
par broyage
voici le plus important site français
une véritable usine et de tripes par
magnétisme les métaux ferreux sont
isolés 60 % du poids d'une voiture
redevient acier mais ce n'est pas
suffisant la difficulté c'est la
récupération des matériaux non
métalliques en particulier des
plastiques pour atteindre 85%
c'est tout l'enjeu valoriser le résidu
du broyage y compris les plastiques
nécessitant un tri complexe
depuis quelques années ce groupe c'est
les traiter les refondre en granulés qui
redeviennent pare chocs ou porte céder
une étape vers l'objectif de 2015
valoriser 95 % du poids des véhicules
d'ici là il faudra être capable de
récupérer les caoutchoucs les verts les
mousses et de collaborer avec les
équipementiers fait à l'éco-conception
qu'il faut apprendre à mettre des
produits valorisables sur les voitures
ou à pouvoir mieux démonter les voitures
demain un travail environnementale
engagée par certains constructeurs mais
ces efforts ne se traduiront que dans
une dizaine d'années quand leur
automobile arriveront dans les casses
hier entre 19h55 et 20 heures nous
étions appelés à offrir cinq minutes de
répit pour la planète
et bien sachez que l'opération a été un
succès avec une chute de 1% de la
consommation d'électricité en france
pendant ce laps de temps à paris en
dehors de la tour eiffel une dizaines de
monuments ont été plongés dans le noir
même chose à lyon marseille toulouse à
rome donc le colisée était dans
l'obscurité
la france non fumeurs depuis hier dans
les lieux publics il faut s'y faire pas
de cigarette sur son lieu de travail
mais des temps de pause que propose des
entreprises pour les accros au tabac me
boutabout des heures travaillées en moi
de fait à chaque société de gérer comme
elle l'entend c'est pause avec une
certaine vigilance roma mais c'est jean
françois meunier le pare brise est tout
neuf
la voiture réparée et la pause cigarette
bien méritée à la maison xi hector est
un gros fumeur un paquet en moyenne mais
au travail avec la nouvelle loi qui
l'obligent à sortir du bâtiment pour
fumer ce technicien se restreint disons
qu'en moyenne je vais fumer par
demi-journée je vais fumer je prendre de
pause avant tout comme c'était à
l'intérieur ou soit opposé sa cigarette
on continue la voiture ou ont fumé
mais le reste de la cigarette
honnêtement je pense qu'on devait
prendre trois ou quatre postes de plus
vous appris combien de temps cette
petite pause tabac par sept postes à bas
prix environ 5-6 minutes 5 à 6 minutes
qui peuvent peser lourd
une heure de travail envolé pour un demi
paquet fumée ici l'entreprise assure ne
pas faire la chasse au posta bas mais
garde un oeil sur la productivité
je pense qu'il faut qu'on reste dans un
cadre raisonnable c'est-à-dire à hauteur
de 2 3 à 4 cigarettes par jour
comment gérer dorénavant les pauses
cigarette une question pour toutes les
entreprises
la loi assure aux salariés 20 minutes de
pause payer pour six heures de travail
mais au delà au delà de l'obligation
légale que l'employeur à d'offrir les
pauses soit obligations de la loi soit
obligations de la convention collective
l'employeur peut interdire un salarié de
décembre pour fumer une cigarette
une décision qui risque fort d'être
impopulaires alors pour maintenir leurs
salariés au travail les entreprises
préfèrent surtout les encourager à
arrêter de fumer
j'en viens à ce mouvement des salariés
d'airbus pour protester contre le projet
de restructuration de l'avionneur et ses
conséquences sociales
un mot d'ordre de mobilisation a été
donné en allemagne les employés menacent
de retarder les livraisons d'avions pour
faire pression sur la direction en
france plusieurs débrayages que massa
nazaire à nombre dans la somme
manifestation à toulouse et puis la
pelle ou président de la république une
lettre adressée à jacques chirac dans
laquelle les salariés font part de leur
inquiétude climat beaucoup plus apaisé à
dunkerque dans le nord le pdg indien
d'arcelormittal est venue rassurer pas
d'emploi supplémentaires supprimés et
puis une production plutôt en
augmentation maria de masse dominique
maes
la direction du site avait tenu à le
préciser la visite était strictement
privé la première à dunkerque pour
lakhsmi mittal
une façon de montrer que depuis la
fusion avec arcelor il ya six mois le
patron ici c'est lui est ici justement
on attendait cette visite pour être
rassurés sur l'avenir et notamment sur
le plan d'investissements promis de 800
millions d'euros d'ici à 2008
le grand patron a voulu apaiser toutes
les inquiétudes
il n'y a rien de nouveau à annoncer nous
avons des programmes d'investissements
court ce que j'ai simplement fait
aujourd'hui c'est rassurer la direction
les employés et les syndicats que ces
programmes suivent leur cours
on continue donc et au pas de charge
lakhsmi mittal a ensuite entamé une
visite du site inauguré en 1962 lui
ligne de dunkerque produit des aciers
plats utilisés notamment par l'industrie
automobile avec 5500 employés 7 millions
de tonnes de production par an
le site est à la dimension du groupe né
de la fusion entre arcelor et mittal
lakhsmi mittal l'a réaffirmé aujourd'hui
dunkerque est considérée comme le coeur
de la stratégie du groupe
d'une part il affirmait que youri
continuation niveau des investissements
donc bon ça nous soulage en partie et en
second lieu qui aurait pas de plans
sociaux c'est-à-dire des suppressions
d'emplois additionnels ce qui a été
prévu
aujourd'hui nous a quand même confirmé
que c'était l'unité la plus performante
du groupe
c'était une unité qu'elle devait
continuer à progresser en production et
aussi réduire ses coûts de gestion
une façon d'entériner un plan de la
direction qui prévoit 300 millions
d'euros d'économies d'ici à l'horizon
pour rester compétitif devant la justice
neuf personnes atteintes d'un cancer du
rpt a décidé à poursuivre l'entreprise
dans laquelle il travaille l usine à des
soucis utiliser une molécule suspecté de
provoquer ces tumeurs laetitia legendre
la reconnaissance de la faute
inexcusable de leur employeur
c'est ce que viennent chercher neuf
salariés de l'usiné chimique adisseo
ayant appartenait auparavant à rhône
poulenc des employés dont le cancer du
rein a été reconnu comme maladie
professionnelle
il y a quatre ans j'ai l'impression que
qui savait et puis que bombe a eu il n'y
a qu'une chose qui compte c'est l'argent
en fin d'année et puis voilà en 2003 les
ouvriers de cette usine de commentry
dans l'allier spécialisée dans la
fabrication de compléments nutritionnels
pour animaux s'émeuvent du nombre de
cancers du rein anormalement élevées au
sein de l'entreprise un taux 20 fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale
la direction affirme aujourd'hui avoir
fait le nécessaire pour protéger au
mieux ses employés nous avons toujours
mis en oeuvre les meilleures pratiques
pour nous prémunir d'éventuels risques
des produits chimiques depuis la
création de l'atelier dans les années 80
de ces la position qu'a défendu notre
avocat c'est pour ça que nous réfutons
la faute inexcusable de l'employeur
mise en cause par certains une molécule
utilisée dans la fabrication de la
vitesse 1le clora s'étale c5 toxiques
selon certains experts à 95% les jours
la base des expérimentations sur des
cellules on peut concéder avec le cesag
d'un cancer
à ce jour 25 personnes ayant travaillé
chez adisseo ont contracté un cancer du
rein 9 ans sont mortes
le jugement a été mis en délibéré au 23
mars en france plus d'un salarié sur dix
est exposés à des produits cancérogènes
la balance le procureur a reçu
aujourd'hui la famille du beau-père de
juniac qui s'est suicidé après sa garde
à vue et qui est très vraisemblablement
hors de cause ses proches veulent que la
vérité soit faite sur cette affaire le
procureur qui a reconnu une maladresse
sont ses termes
expliquant que jean-eric et mia avait
été reconvoqué deux heures après sa
remise en liberté du côté de l'en quête
de nouvelles fouilles ont été
entreprises avec sur place une centaine
de policiers de gendarmes autour de
l'appartement familial de la prison
ferme pour ces trafiquants de bébés
bulgare les acheteurs départ en mal
d'enfant également été sanctionné mais
dans la majorité dans la majorité des
cas ils ont obtenu un sursis yasmina
farber stéphane guillemot
ce couple avait acheté deux enfants le
tribunal les condamne à deux ans de
prison dont un avec sursis
ce sauveur prison ferme pour deux autres
acheteurs mais pour 34 parents qui
avaient aussi payer leur bébé la
sanction est plus clémente
et justement c'est bien oui je suis moi
turquie vous êtes toujours avec votre
petit toujours et alors vous êtes
satisfait de ce jugement il commencé
tous issus de la communauté des gens du
voyage ses parents avaient raconté
l'impossibilité pour eux d'adopter en
france les enfants restent avec eux
tribunal a pris en considération la
détresse des parents ce mal d'enfant en
même temps le tribunal a rappelé la loi
l'interdiction absolue d'acheter un être
humain sur 23 maires bulgare vendeuse
dink a été la seule à comparaître
le tribunal condamne son compagnon et
ancien proxénètes mais il relaxe la
jeune femme
tout ça s'est fait dans son dos donc
justice a bien tranchée à mon sens pas
vu que cette personne n'était pas
coupable est plutôt victime aux
organisateurs les marchandes enfants
sont condamnés de 3 à 6 ans de prison
certains des marchés des femmes
enceintes en bulgarie d'autres touché
des commissions sur les ventes
c'est la première fois qu'un trafic
d'enfants étaient jugés en france les
délits de traite des êtres humains et de
provocation à l'abandon d'un enfant ont
permis de juger vendeurs des acheteurs
mais les magistrats ont noté un manque
en droit français la vente d'un bébé
n'est pas une infraction
le juge van ruymbeke renvoyé devant le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
dans le cadre de l' affaire clearstream
met en cause nicolas sarkozy estimant
qu'il s'agit d'une délices d'une
décision politique sans surprise
dominique wernert renaud van ruymbeke ne
décolère pas son renvoi devant le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature et
dit-il une décision politique dans le
dossier clearstream
le juge estime être l'une des cibles de
nicolas sarkozy il a eu de cesse de
m'agresser dans son dans ces deux livres
qu'il a écrits
pourquoi très désobligeant mon égard il
dit sur tf1
il ya trois mois qu'ils étaient victimes
de l'alliance d'un corbeau et d'un juge
bon j'ai jamais que j'aimais compris
d'alliance et oui qu'un petit détail que
ce sarko suivi c'est que c'est moi qui
ai prouvé que les contres t'es folle ça
fait des années que je me bats pour
essayer de le faire sortir des dossiers
difficiles c'est pas le premier chausse
trapes combat on m'a tendu mon message
moi je continue encore
j'estime que la justice à doigts est
également une mise en cause que le
ministre de l'intérieur partie civile
dans le dossier récuse que monsieur ben
non nouvelle qui finissent bien le
rapport extrêmement sévère l'inspection
sont nombreuses qui d'un côté égratine
le juge van ruymbeke sa rencontre en
avril 2004 dans le cabinet d'un avocat
avec jean louis gergorin
personnage central de la sphère des pros
listings s'est fait hors procédure
un rapport qui de l'autre reconnaît que
le juge a agi dans le souci exclusif de
la recherche de la vérité
en septembre dernier le supérieur
hiérarchique de renaud van ruymbeke
avait remis au garde des sceaux
un rapport qui dédouanent elle juge
aujourd'hui pascal clément justifie la
saisine du csm
je renvoie mais je vendre une belle
devant le juge des juges et le juge d
juché conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
ce n'est pas le garde des sceaux j'ai
bien dit elle ça n'a rien à voir avec la
politique
renault vendre une bête voit donc sa
promotion compromise conséquence il
reste à l'instruction chargé des
dossiers politico financiers les plus
sensibles
la campagne électorale avec hier soir à
grenoble la contre attaque de ségolène
royal qui n'a pas ménagé le candidat de
l'ump ségolène royal qui a annoncé une
série de mesures à destination de la
jeunesse le détail avec j'ai vite à mr
gay mady diarra attend attend lui dit
patrick mennucci l'homme de confiance
qui organise ses meetings
puis c'est le moment d'entrer dans la
foule une salle bien
lee hier ségolène royal voulait faire
forte impression au moins autant que
nicolas sarkozy dans ses meetings
candidate ségolène royal car elles
s'estiment désavantagés pour la première
fois s'en prend à certains médias qui à
ses yeux roulent pour le candidat de
l'ump veulent la discréditer pourquoi il
ne faudrait pas changé de candidates
j'entendais ça ce matin je le redis ce
soir qu'avec vous nous n'avons pas peur
et que nous resterons debout une
candidate remontée excédé d'entendre
qu'elle n'aurait pas de propositions
alors hier soir au chapitre jeunesse
elle s'est voulue concrètes création
d'un droit au premier emploi pas plus de
six mois pour un jeune sans travail ou
formation possibilité d'un prêt de dix
mille euros à taux zéro permis de
conduire payé par l'état pour les
titulaires du ceap et une esquisse de
programme qu'elle oppose aux contres
modèle selon elle de l'ump l'ascenseur
social comme le dit jamel reste bloquée
au sous-sol et le modèle que la droite
propose à nos enfants soient compétitifs
ne pense qu'à toi même et surtout tu es
toi ségolène royal a longuement célébré
une france coloré métissée
globalement son discours a plutôt fait
mouche l apéro monte vraiment une france
métissée et où on attendait que ça quoi
voilà nous on fait partie de ce pays est
là et bien de nous
franchement on est content hier ces
supporteurs ont retrouvé de l'énergie
le 11 février quand elle présentera son
programme c'est aux français que
ségolène royal veut redonner envie 2002
villepin en visite officielle en
bulgarie a manifesté sa solidarité avec
les infirmières bulgares condamnées à
mort en libye le premier ministre
portait pelé lui a son revers un ruban
sur lequel était très critique vous
n'êtes pas seuls explique encore
français et en bulgare le nic de
villepin qui appelle l'europe à se
mobiliser en écoute
nous ne sommes pas prêts à voir se
prolonger le calvaire de ces infirmières
nous ne sommes pas prêts à accepter que
plusieurs années encore elle soit retenu
si injustement alors ce calvaire
il est important que nous puissions y
mettre fin rapidement
en accord avec le président de la
république française j'ai demandé au
ministre des affaires étrangères
philippe douste blazy de bien vouloir
saisir ses partenaires européens avec
son collègue bulgare les 12 et 13
février prochain lors de la prochaine
réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères nous devons étudier tous les
moyens d'obtenir dans télé les plus
rapides
la libération des infirmières à
l'occasion du congrès mondial contre la
peine de mort organisée par la ligue des
droits de l'homme apparaît la chine est
au banc des accusés elle est le premier
pays au monde à utiliser à la chaîne la
peine capitale
des exécutions qui alimente le trafic
d'organes karine comazzi clip chasselas
en 2008 la chine accueillera les jeux
olympiques vaste fête pour les uns faute
de goût pour les autres au moins 4000
prisonniers seraient exécutés chaque
année soit 10 par jour une véritable
cérémonie organisée dans des stades
l'exécution en chine est utilisé plus à
des fins de terreur c'est à dire d'un
style et la terreur dans le coeur de la
population que à des fins punitif
il est porté de coups du condamné son
crime écrit en grosses lettres en chine
68 chefs d'inculpation sont passibles de
la peine de mort cela va de la tromperie
à l'assurance au trafic de drogue
ces campagnes appelé frapper fort
s'intensifie au moment des faits le
nombre des gris cuts et augmentera
durant la période que nous commençons
maintenant entre janvier 2007 et août
2008 pour être sûr que les jeux
olympiques se passe bien
le gouvernement chinois va se donner
tous les mains les moyens pour comme il
dit maintenir la stabilité sociale
mais ces exécutions ont une autre
finalité le trafic d'organes un commerce
lucratif dénoncé depuis dix ans par les
dissidents en octobre dernier un
reporter britannique filmé une
transaction en caméra cachée dans le
plus grand centre de transplantation
on lui propose pour son père malade 1 x
76 mille euros trois semaines de délai
fait que c'est vrai que beaucoup
d'organes proviennent des prisonniers
qui ont été exécutés oui c'est vrai les
condamnés à mort ont fait de la même
chose en donnant leurs organes avant de
mourir il se rachète auprès de la
société
c'est bien le célèbre dissident rares et
où a passé 19 ans ou la houga et le
goulag chinois ce trafic d'organes il le
connaît et il consacre sa vie à le
dénoncer
la police appelle l'hôpital la veille de
l'exécution l'hôpital près partout le
patient receveur et l'ambulance
médicalisée ensuite dans l'ambulance
le docteur ne chôme pas il coupe
they are 1,1 fois un coeur une cornée la
pauvre et après ils amènent les organes
à l'hôpital par la transplantation
voilà la procédure d'arrestation en
juillet 2005 le vice ministre de la
santé a reconnu l'existence de ce trafic
pour mieux le réguler at il promis
une manière de limiter les abus qui
entoure la peine de mort
sans renoncer à l'appliquer en france
exercice grandeur nature pour ce
scénario catastrophe autour d'une
raffinerie suppose être en feu après une
fuite plus de 500 pompiers militaires et
policiers sur le terrain
l'autoroute a7 a été coupée le mans
virginie fichet philippe suivait une
intervention grandeur nature pour un
scénario fictif mais catastrophe
le théâtre la raffinerie de feyzin la
scène du gasoil qui s'échappe d'une cuve
et s'enflamme le risque ultime une
explosion qui produirait une boule de
feu jaune hermétique
aucune circulation en tous les points
l'autoroute a7 coupé pendant 20 minutes
500 personnels opérationnels sur le
terrain et dans les rues une atmosphère
de ville en guerre la simulation se veut
la plus réaliste au possible
70 habitants environ sont ainsi évacuées
vers le gymnase communal sans panique
le but est avant tout de tester la
communication et la coordination entre
les différents acteurs
côté
mais bon faut voir si en réalité ça va
être
organisé par est à feyzin l'exercice
n'est pas à nous dans l'explosion à la
raffinerie qui avait fait 17 morts en
1966 est dans toutes les mémoires
quand on est maire de feyzin j'imagine
pas que ce soit pas la première de ses
préoccupations et de créer toutes les
conditions pour que la population se
sente en sécurité à côté d'une
installation industrielle majeure mais
en même temps c'est quoi elle c'est de
l'emploi
c'est de la richesse donc c'est pas une
installation qui est rejetée car au delà
de l'entraînement pour les autorités
l'exercice a aussi un rôle pédagogique
il faut que nous nous apprenions en
quelque sorte à nos concitoyens les
risques véritables qui courent les
moyens que nous avons prévu pour leur
porter l'aide qui leur sera nécessaire
le moment venu et ainsi le risque est
mieux acceptée en matière de sécurité le
test du jour n'est que la partie visible
de l'iceberg
chaque semaine d entraînement internes
ont lieu à la raffinerie de feyzin
en bretagne les bénévoles sont toujours
à pied d'oeuvre sur les plages souillées
par des galettes de fioul et des objets
mazout et les élus réclament des aides
pour faire face à la pollution
jacques devaux miss univers la pollution
est toujours la même
dites-lui sournoise des micros boulette
ou des paquets de biscuits englués de
pétrole
à chaque marée il en revient qu'il faut
constamment ramassées sur les plages les
communes se débrouillent seuls employés
communaux et bénévoles pour le travail
ou ce qu'on attendait c'est la présence
sur le terrain et puis j'ai déjà les
bras les bras pour hama pour ramasser
alors c'est vrai que là jusqu'à
maintenant on se sente est un petit peu
un petit peu seul et l'alcyon le navire
de dépollution de la marine croise au
large
seul élément visible de l'action de
l'état pour l'heure le préfet du
finistère a rappelé que la pollution ne
justifiait pas le déclenchement du plan
polmar le choix n'est pas entre colmar
et pas paul marc pour dire au maire ça
vous êtes tout seul soit vous êtes
épauler est-ce que je viens leur dire
c'est que même sans polmar mêmes sans
déclenchement de moyens massifs qui ne
se justifie pas on peut pas laisser les
mères tout seul ça ce sujet là sont les
accompagner un peu plus loin dans les
côtes d'armor
le conseil général fait constater par
huissier la pollution alors je peux
constater donc la présence d'un paquet
de biscuits donc totalement maculé de
sang carbure autant de preuve à
présenter s'il épilogue de cette
pollution se déroule devant les
tribunaux car il est certain qu'il
faudra du temps pour venir à bout des
milliers de taches de pétrole coincé
dans les rochers du temps et de l'argent
à locquirec la facture s'élève déjà à
4000 euros
l'actualité sportive les championnats du
monde de ski débute demain en suède art
par le super g masculin une épreuve où
le français antoine dénériaz fait partie
d outsider ambiance dans le camp
français la veille de la course envoyés
spéciaux nathanaël de rincquesen régis
mater le calme avant la tempête
le paisible village doré s'apprête à
changer de rythme pendant l'année ici un
millier d'hommes et de femmes vivent au
bord du lac pendant quinze jours
il s'apprête à accueillir cent mille
personnes pour les championnats du monde
de ski notre village est désormais
transformée en camp retranché
alain et restaurateurs à aurait depuis
près de dix ans cette compétition va
permettre de faire connaître les skis en
suède
la civilisation nous rejoint ici donc
c'est bien on ça vient de partout
d'angleterre on a des touristes anglais
qui viennent skier le côté exotique bon
il n'y a pas la même la même panique sur
les pistes que dans les alpes donc ça
devient ça devient populaire parce que
on ne fait pas la queue on monte on
descend on monte on descend dans cette
région du monde
la température peut atteindre les moins
40 degrés le matin il fait doux le vent
et la pluie balayer la piste
les touristes souffrent les champions
aussi l'équipe de france doit écourter
son entraînement
cette année c'est un hiver un peu
particulier avec souvent des conditions
assez chaud des conditions de piste un
peu particulière peu importe la météo
derrière antoine deneriaz les français
sont pleins d'ambitions le titre
olympique conquis l'an passé les a
décomplexé mon ambition c'est vraiment
de tenter notre chance et puis bien
entendu on espère glaner quelques
médailles mais bon c'est du ski alpin il
ya beaucoup de paramètres et on espère
que les paramètres seront avec nous si
depuis quelques années aux jeux
olympiques l'équipe de france affiche
une réussite insolente
le bilan des championnats du monde est
nettement moins flatteurs à horrues ici
en suède
les français veulent mettre un terme à
six ans de disette en accédant à leur
premier podium mondial depuis 2001 et
les championnats du monde de ski seront
à suivre demain à partir de 12 heures 25
sur france 2 de maromme c'est
l'ouverture du tournoi des six nations
pour le quinze de france un quinze de
france qui reste sur un automne
douloureux avec deux lourdes défaites
contre les all-blacks et qui en cette
année de coupe du monde espère démarrer
sur une bonne note demain en italie sur
place christophe duchiron frédérick
basile ce matin les bleus ont pris
l'avion pour l'italie avec à bord du
travail sur ordinateur de la lecture de
magazines et du jeu vidéo en veux tu en
voilà
et voilà comment les bleus ont survolé
les alpes eux qui ces derniers temps un
peu de mal à dominer leur sujet
nous sommes début 2007 c'est en quelque
sorte la dernière ligne droite avant la
coupe du monde qui débutera en septembre
l'encadrement du quinze de france a
réuni quarante joueurs une large revue
d'effectif qui va durer sept semaines le
temps de disputer le tournoi des six
nations
bref il faut aujourd'hui avec la
concordance des temps préparer l'avenir
et répondre présent
mon sens fait de donner une priorité à
l'heure ou à l'autre saisir ou tournois
ou à la coupe du monde parce que
forcément si on il faut être performant
d'abord dans le tournoi pour espérer
ensuite faire partir ou plein en cette
année de mondialisation du rugby l'heure
est donc à la concurrence
les bleus entament le début de la lutte
finale difficile exercice à
l'entraînement cette semaine
c'est à dire qu'à force de ne pas se
trouver l'équipe de france se cherche
une troisième ligne
une charnière en arrière alors que se
profile le premier match de l'année face
à l'italie une équipe que l'on dit en
progrès constants depuis son admission
dans le tournoi en l'an 2000 une équipe
dont la plupart des joueurs évoluent
dans les meilleurs championnats en
france et en angleterre mais une équipe
qui reste sur sept défaites consécutives
contre les bleus qui malgré tout restent
sur leurs gardes
quand se dressent les shows latin il
faut jouer libérés face à face à ces
italiens où on va être attendu au notre
défense on se rencontre notre défense
notre conquête
si on a faim après notre jeu soit pas
parfait évidemment le premier match pas
plus tard que samedi à 14 heures la
france de rome contre l'italie
on a beau entamer la dernière ligne
droite on attend les bleus au premier
tournant
et le match de rugby italie france sera
à suivre demain à partir de 14h sur
notre chaîne en basket images étonnantes
au texas lors d'un match perd scolaire
el paso une étudiante à deux secondes de
la fin de la rencontre a réussi un tir
d'anthologie de l'autre bout du terrain
vous voyez elle a marqué un panier pour
donner la victoire à son équipe
62 à 60 dans la plus pure tradition des
chanteuses de gospel liz mc comb et ce
soir à paris où elle donne un concert la
chanteuse américaine vient de sortir son
huitième album des chansons inédites et
d'autres du répertoire olivier les news
à thierry breton
il s'agit bien d'une loge et d'une
valise de stars mais la beauté en
question se moque des apparences excusez
moi monsieur poli et très pieuse loue le
seigneur bénisse au gésu allez tous en
rythme avec moi u19 sont des prêts à
servir dieu a honoré le gospel
ramené aux etats unis elle est
découverte par un producteur français
non
la france où liz may compte d'un un
concert gratuit à l'olympia en 1998 en
faveur des plus démunis
un joli geste la philosophie de
l'artiste ici c'est la misère ou alors
le monde a besoin de gens comme moi qui
apporte la paix et l'amour
louis meyer le monde n'aura jamais assis
fille de pasteur elle a commencé à
chanter dans les églises sur les genoux
de sa soeur
modesto méconnu
aujourd'hui elle communie sur scène avec
la nouvelle génération 60 élèves de la
maîtrise de paris encore tout intimidé
super rabelais or en dieu mais cette
musique ne m'a réservé à l'église church
elle qui chante un en première partie
deux raids chasse james brown désire
sortir le gospel de sa chapelle
et pourtant les concerts de liz mc comb
conserve quelque chose de sacré c'est la
fin de ce journal je vous remercie de
votre attention tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet puis le point 8 valérie
maurice 20h50 une soirée de polar avec
un flim à flic téléfilm inédit
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13h excellente fin
de soirée sur france 2
le ministre